okay well welcome to the uh wrap up
session for problem three
and uh got to remind everyone that there
are 16 days left until our glorious art
show
is all right
you look at
16 days left and and it'll be that's a
power of two so it must be significant
and uh
uh
and
we'll have some
information about how to get
how to do rudimentary gray level type
setting uh anyway we can will supply
uh sample
format so that you don't have to deal
with all the bit level hassles
of some of these machines that a few of
us already know how to
how to poke into a little bit um
let me see
so uh can i ask how many people have
actually
actually a plan to use that digitizing
equipment that haven't done so
yet
they said they were going to maybe close
the accounts at the end of the month was
one two three four five six seven okay
does it how many people have actually
used the digitizing equipment
successfully
one two three four five six
okay so it does still work as far as
anybody knows
as of last week as of last week okay
well
um uh
so those of you who still want to use it
and
uh you you know that that you have six
examples of of success that people you
could you could ask if you got into
troubles but i would
hope that you do it uh before it breaks
down because software rock sets in
everywhere
okay
in fact i think they installed a new
memory on coyote last weekend and
uh it was a little bit
flaky
for a while i'm not sure if it you know
they improved it by adding more memory
and uh and now it runs only half as fast
as before something like that
okay so now problem
three um
what are the
what are the uh what are the results how
hard
people do i'll report i had 14.
um
i think of course nobody's checked my
program
my program thinks it has 14
what to uh okay um a neo we haven't got
a complete cover yet you haven't got a
complete cover you have an incomplete
you have you have
you have it down to six thousand sixty
five thousand five hundred
um
well we can't cover all the faults and
the ten the ten we're missing are
probably
dominating cases okay so you're missing
ten frauds
and they're tough to get those 10. yeah
that's what you're saying and that's the
team of o'neill and
and andy golden uh-huh okay
um
so um
uh
don't feel embarrassed it's okay
tang
our king is uh john
and
dimitri
and
we haven't gotten any solutions yeah how
close are you we have uh covered
or accept two for
me
another fall is undetectable
yeah in other words you've got you've
got uh you've got two that you think you
could detect probably but you don't know
for sure because you've never detected
it all right i mean i might be
i know for sure that you can detect it
oh you do yeah
wow
how do you know that uh well
we grind through the 64k possibilities
oh but you didn't you didn't take a note
of which one it was well we didn't want
to do it that way again
guess
okay
um
trying to find the
some of my notes here well while you're
talking okay so uh
all but two in that case how did you get
the
the uh so so you
well
let's let's just i want to first get the
bottom line and then i'll go into the
thing karen
you're working with um marianne and
narith and we have all but a roughing 18
of little peckers
over 18.
okay
um
we've been one bug away from getting the
whole lot
would you like to
describe the grand scheme anyway later
on okay
now um
uh
yes here's my
thing okay now let's see what uh
to make sure you've already you you're
with john and um yeah
and uh arif
covered andy's covered kathy
i'll be working with roger and mark
we've got a solution with 13 um 13 is
that the best you could do okay
you mean you're missing 13.
you mean you covered it with 13. yes
that's remarkable i'd like to hear um
but you as you've paid your dues for the
previous one so i asked uh
to divide up the uh
this description of how you got 13 okay
marianne from amy i'm working with rich
he's at 10 right now but we've got down
to about 15.
15 now you're covering it with what oh
15 not covered
i see we ought to have a way to
distinguish this by calling it minus 15.
um okay
so uh
uh
and let's see
um
john you were mentioned
so you and i'm not lady tucker you and
andy yeah yeah we haven't found cover
yet either
okay well um
let me see
i'm
okay well i was wondering how many
people would find
who would find one because uh i i don't
have my my notes on it here but what
happened to me was similar i suppose i i
tried
uh well let's see let me let me find out
uh neil how did you get the how did you
get up to 10
um
tried
the the cover that
the partial cover that we have so far
was generated in a number of different
ways
um
some of the inputs were random
some of them were entered by hand
and some of them were
generated by program
okay so you've got
three classes of of ways of awake one is
random so what did you so so you got a
lot of them by random or hundred uh no
not many of them are random
but they're just a few animals that
happened to detect faults that
uh the others hadn't detected so
okay so so then the ones by
by uh
program were determined how
um by a non-exhausted forcing scheme
uh so it would uh
it would give up in other words it would
it would try if it would non-exhaustive
means that it didn't try all
possibilities but it would it would it
would it would try it would try um
the possibilities it thought were
promising and if they didn't work
it wouldn't
it wouldn't
back up uh
that it would backtrack but it wouldn't
go be it wouldn't try all the the
possibilities so
uh for a number of gates it would just
give up
and say i can't do this
okay
and and uh
uh
how many gates did you
cover that way
um
i don't know i mean roughly most of them
or do you just
oh okay and then you got some by hand
yeah then i had some by hand and how did
you
decide to
decide to do it by hand well i had uh
um
i just had a program that let me
they essentially random but i was using
uh some cubes
um from other ones i had gotten
and
it would let me enter them
an input
and see if it determined any faults that
the others have determined yet
and if so i would keep it
so you got but you got these guesses by
by some previous run
what yes i mean these these things these
you you're in something by hand from a
previous run or something it wasn't that
you that you looked at the multiplying
circuit and said uh
boy i bet you if i multiplied 68 times
700
or what i guess it has to be less 2x6 by
two minutes well that would that it
would produce this fall no actually some
of them i did
say this is a multiplier circuit
and i should maybe try this one
i can't remember if those those were the
ones i ended up keeping yeah okay but i
did use that no
okay
well in my own
case i it says
something like that i mean i had
i had i tried random
a random greedy approach which as we
talked about last time
first is to see how
how it was
what the territory was like
and i found out that
see i don't have
i don't know if i have a print out of
that
yeah here would say for example
hits for gate 775 but all these gates
are increased by factor three
217 uh times it was stuck at zero for 33
i detected stuck at
that one and then there was this one
there were
there were 10 gates
in fact that in the first 500 random
trials or 400 or something random trials
um
never
never were stuck at one never were
never one never got a one on them yeah
um
and uh there was there was this one gate
uh for example had
um
only two case only two cases that i
detected stuck at zero and only two
cases stuck at one
so this this was a gate that
that uh seemed to be uh probably equally
likely between zero and one but it was
it wasn't very important in the output
because
usually it's its fault wouldn't get
through you so even though it was
you know even though it's it it was
probably fairly easy to set to zero or
one the other guys that that are needed
in order to get to the close to all 15
right to the 15th output yes ah well let
me see what that was um what did i say 2
2
that's 10 54. it's very near the
it's very near the uh
the end
of the circuit but i i haven't got a
good symbolic identification of these
which is which is a mistake i should
have
i should have added another field in my
record that says what
what gate is this
uh other than a numerical indication for
so that i could understand but there i
have another case where it was where
where the thing never occurred stuck at
one or i mean never occurred with the
value one and i detected it but three
times zero
and that was very
that was very close to the to the final
output
so it probably was
was used by
you know some
it's probably uh
um an and gate or something where the
other or the other thing is always
canceling out this one in the unless
it's ended with warm something like that
um and so
um
so i broke i too broke down down and did
an exhaustive uh i tried all 65 000
inputs and printed out every time one of
those 10
guys
was stuck at a gate was had a stuck at
thing and that i mean you know i knew
that this wasn't generalized to the next
higher level case
but i was i had no other other i tried
my back tracking method on it and
and
it worked very very well for the ones
near the beginning of the circuit
it would you know instantaneously print
the answer
but when i got to these these these uh
10 tough ones and i tried it um
uh i it just went on and on forever just
it's uh
if you've
ever done much backtracking you you know
the symptoms of the thing there's
you're typically
going back and forth between three or
four levels of
of a search tree
and
and
you you uh you suppose it'll eventually
you'll eventually stop very
i remember the first time this
once when i was an undergraduate i tried
to to program the machine to to find a
solution to this solitaire game where
you jump all the pegs together and try
to get one left at the end
i see that it's now a problem in abacus
magazine it just came out a month a week
or so ago uh
people are supposed to send in your
solutions to this to this thing and i
wonder if other people will discover
well like my my program
i wrote a nice general program that
would work for arbitrary um shaped
boards
and i tested it out on a on a four by
four uh
case and i could jump it no i'll work
fine so then i put in the whole the real
board which is i think
nine by nine
or seven by seven something like that
and um
and and let it run and i and i stayed at
the computing center
and i and i
was waiting to get my answers and
finally at eight o'clock in the morning
i decided i better stop the machine and
take a look at how far it got and
and my best estimate was that it would
have been another 200 centuries before
it would have
at that rate you know it was
it was still
it you know there was a sort of a 48
step decision tree and it hadn't
reconsidered this 16th
branch yet of it's where it was going it
was backtracking
well um
and uh what i found with this exhaustive
search
was uh
was that there were some
gates that there was there was a
one gate that had um
only two ways to get it
to get it out equal to one does anybody
know
this
does anybody find this thing same thing
and it was um
and the only two ways were to where to
multiply 199 times 247
equals 49153
and this also equals 247 times 199
and those were the only cases that if my
program is right
um that gave
that gave one of the gates and then
there were two there were two others
that had only four ways to to uh
to get it now if you look at these in
binary
this number is very close to three times
two to the
fourteen
three times sixteen
it's very close to that and then my
other my other hard cases were
149 times
220
equals 3 2 7 8 0.
you can see
close to 2 to the 15th here
147
times 223
equals three two seven eight one
um
and then the corresponding one with the
factors reversed was another case
and uh
and then um
um
i guess there's
just a few a few tough examples of 231
times 140
2 is 3 2
8 02.
this is all in decimal in binary the
the patterns are
somewhat interesting too but um
the main thing is that the binary
pattern of the product is very has lots
of consecutive ones in it
or lots of consecutive zeros that that
required a ripple carry that of past a
lot of ones
223 147 149
well this
this is this one was half of the
previous of that example one six three i
know
okay those are the
those are the uh
the things that seem to be hard to
multiply i mean that when you multiply
them give give other outputs and from
this i would
suppose that if i go to
the next higher case 16 by 16
i
it would help to first factor numbers
that are near
2 to the 31
and find out and try uh
try inputs like that maybe if i were
still stuck with this kind of a
stuff this kind of an approach where my
backtracking wasn't wasn't working
however talking to the people who got 13
it looks like their method might might
uh it was much better at backtracking
and some it's um
so they discovered that
some some secret way to
to get through
um or else i had to plug in my program
um
you know uh now um okay so so you so you
uh
got
so so anyway
there were these ten left that
that were missing and peng you said four
left or
well three actually three two i mean
yeah right so the two that
i imagine two of them are i probably on
this list here right
and how did you get the uh to that step
to that okay we um
we tried the uh four bit case
in the 5a case and we solved it
and get all these solutions
i mean the um
that for the forbidden case we have
five pairs of inputs
oh let's yeah let's ask that question so
you've got maybe other people try that
so
the four
four by four multiplication you could
cover it with five yes
and the five by five is seven
so that means uh
yeah well let's suggest
up there
eight by eight yeah it suggests a
formula two n minus three doesn't matter
there's a conjecture
okay uh
right
yeah and do you think these are the best
but does anybody else try the small
cases to compare do we have
yeah
i'm fairly sure the five is four by four
is exactly
uh we would expect that to be a
fairly easy one though tested on the
negative one
right
well
um no i guess that we would
we would have a little trouble on the
one by one but uh
what is it it's a
it's a single land gate and so you would
have to
test it twice wouldn't you wanted to
see whether it was stuck at the wrong
value
uh okay
yeah
zero by zero
always
always like list going both directions
if you can okay so anyway this is uh
this is our best and this is probably
correct though okay
and so now can you use the four by four
somehow yeah we try to recognize
patterns or something
and try to feed it
recognize patterns of uh i mean what the
what these
things were the total number of
the pairs that's that were in the
solution
so
we had about
about 70 uh
pairs totalers
something like that for the 4x4 case 70
70 gates 70 pairs of input pairs of
inputs yeah that that combinations of
five of them would give a solution oh i
see 70 ways to take
is that
something like this
70 good how did you what are these 70
representatives we generated all the
solutions for the 4x4 games
yeah and the gates are
well i see this was an exhaustive search
it was an exhaustive place you know of
all the covers
it's hard to find mcbusky sort of thing
yeah so the uh
um
so now let's see uh you've got uh how
many gates in that seven you get 70
gates and seven and so you you had uh
and also seven is that a coincidence no
i don't think it was seven some of the
number but
i mean the number of
and one of those gates couldn't be
right two of us had gates in fact can't
be covered two of the gates in the four
by four case are
are always zero
okay yeah that's right somebody said one
was feeding into enough
no
they weren't zero but that was three by
three
okay
so um
uh maybe it's always prime
fibonacci number minus one
that will that will do it and and you
looked at those sets of five to see if
there would if there was some you looked
at them in binary or something and seen
if you could generalize this to
something that would help with the uh
with the eight by eight
this uh
uh intuitively i i would say this this
approach of looking for patterns would i
would i wouldn't trust the patterns too
much because i knew that
this uh this end around method that we
had of going three to two three to two
uh doesn't mean that the four by four is
a subset of the eight by eight if we had
a if we did it more recursively where we
where we uh kept the two trees separate
and then combined them somehow to last
step
um a four by four would have would would
be a
definite sort of a sub module of the egg
right but it isn't um but it would still
give uh give insights into the kinds of
i mean i think the a lot of the circuit
is the final parallel ladder
that uh
that combines the last two commands
and those are that adder depends in a
different way in the 8x8 case than it
did in the 4x4 case on the on the on the
inputs
so
so that was an exhaustive uh covering
search that's interesting
because how long did that take was it it
was pretty fast for the four by four it
was like
20 minutes maybe
for the five by five to
we didn't finish it
so you just this is uh they've found so
far
yeah
um
they uh
my my professor uh
marshall hall was my advisor and he he
was sort of famous for the remark that
in the combinatorial problem
um
uh if you
if you uh
um
get another order of magnitude of
computing resources you only get to you
only get to do one more case of a
combinatorial problem i mean
usually
um
and uh people were using that as an
argument saying well
if you're only going to get one more
case then
then
uh you shouldn't uh
worry about the fact that your memory is
is uh it isn't as big as you want
because even if you had one a lot bigger
you would only get one more case
and this seemed to satisfy a lot of
people until you try to use the room
backwards and say okay since you don't
since
you know let's give you one tenth as
much memory so you have only one less
case
and they've been like that
all right now
all right so so that's the
um
so so the the did those actually
uh help them in conjecturing that good
patterns for the
for the uh was it
successful
wasn't that successful
you mean to
ask his secret patterns
now actually we have
a very fast simulator
so we could
use random patterns
very quickly the simulator would tell
you what all the all the um what canvas
we had
all the all the all the cover all the
gates you were all the other faults you
had right and so we went up to having
six folds left
how did you do this fast simulator
and see
i mean
it wasn't it wasn't
different from what we talked about in
class class thursday
and
it was actually what doing
doing the actual multiplication of the
pair of numbers
802 times
okay so you so so it was going through
uh the circuit in
in uh with a lot of bits of
using 32 bits at a time i means
something this simulator of the
multiplication rate in parallel
so it would do those four loops in your
statement in parallel
understanding the problem and then we
did that multiplication once each for
each stuck at full
the for loops would go in parallel so
you're
so you're doing lots of gates that's
that's interesting how do you get the
parallelism on the for loops you you
have 32 bit
right
you don't need that you need almost 16
bits in the 8 bit multiplier yeah so you
do all those
shifts and and xors and so on
in the circuit in parallel rather than
doing
different stuck at folds in front
okay so so you took the the formulas
that we had for the
for stuck at faults and that gave you
802
well that's what i don't i don't quite
see the you've got six you've got
parallelism in two possible directions
and i don't understand which is which i
mean what i could imagine for example we
we we had sets in the on the on the
board last time you know s sub n where s
of n was uh something for gate n
right and and uh s of n since it's a set
you could represent it by a 102 bit
vector
and then you could you could uh you know
our operations on sn were
essentially uh uh exclusive ors and
and and such like
uh based on um
on values of uh
of the gates and the and the other s's
we did the other direction of parallel
okay so that's it yeah so that's what i
want to
get on the tape on the table what is the
other direction of caroline which is
that our our circuit
our simulation of the circuit worked in
parallel
so that perhaps there were a total of 30
horse ends and
xors to do one multiplication
how did you represent the sets
the sets the the the the the the
thoughts this the set of okay the faults
were then
represented because so you could only
test one fault for one multiplication
okay and so you just
could also so this would say does this
multiplication
uh give you such and such a fault right
uh-huh
okay that was done just by
setting that particular gate to that
value
okay
and then and uh and just a few
operations to to to answer that question
that's interesting
okay
now uh so if you had
these other two gates covered how many
how i mean you guys have all the
software that covers
solids covering problems how many do you
have
in
cases you have that cover the other all
but those call the two
i haven't run that i haven't got that
yet
this kind of approach i think makes even
more sense when you have only a few
gates which you are interested in
whether they are covered up yeah
right because that's uh
that's in fact
you know in this this it might be this
guy here or one of them you know this
this one gate uh
needed the
all the ones in this in this binary
number
uh these were the only two ways to get
it
and
and i suppose by
you know
number theory there would be another
case where
where these numbers just wouldn't happen
to occur
on another i mean i'm on nine by nine
problem or something there would be
a case where there just weren't two
suitable factors
in the right in the right range
but actually i think if one were only
interested in a few cases of a few gates
there might be a very simple method to
compute it and that for those gates
compute the expressions in terms of some
gate values
essentially
and then
just plug in those guys gateway now
let's do some symbolic
calculation for the gates of real
interest today that's uh one one
possible that's a that that would yeah
and the symbolic calculation
can always blow up because the number of
min terms can be large but still it
might be small it might it probably
wouldn't you know it would be it's at
most 65 000
uh i mean
to calculate a formula
it can actually you know whenever you
get out of the textbook examples the
formulas get real large no i don't mean
in terms of the inputs oh i mean in
terms of some actual gate values
okay output values of certain gates
given yeah i see in terms of previous
gates
and gates afterwards too so the thing is
once you once you calculate the
gate values throughout it might not be
too difficult to do this
now let's see who is one are you with
karen and yeah this was just the neat
method there no
it was that we were no
what okay well i want that was my next
question
about the neat method
or whatever the right adjective was rtv
to build that proliferation
are we on yeah
um
well it's funny we spent the first two
weeks kind of in a theoretical vacuum i
think we didn't
see that the hard part of the problem
would be covering a few very very hard
to find cases
and so we were trying to work up a
scheme
sort of elaborate scheme to guide the
choice of
um
we kind of assumed that the set size for
each of the
faults the set of inputs that tested it
was about the same but equal for all the
faults which of course isn't
and so we were trying to
guide the choice of the
inputs that would be in the cover based
on that kind of assumption
um but in the process we developed some
tools that were helpful later so it's
really been only the past couple days
that we've been working on the actual
problem
um
of trying to force the output at a
certain gate
to
to be
particular a particular value and
propagate backwards
so we didn't we weren't thinking really
algebraically i mean it's interesting to
me to hear
people that you know we're looking for
yeah okay i i i do want to let because
mike's got a lot of things and i can
roger i have a lot of things so i i
guess i should i
i want to try to
work
we tried to calculate the probability
based on the assumption that the problem
the probability of each input being zero
or one was
about equal the probability of a value
on any given line
in the circuit
um
and use that heuristic to guide the
backward search this
exhaustive search is sort of which
branch to
to check out first
um
tell them about the initial what we did
initially
uh you are essentially trying to use
some kind of greedy algorithm initially
so to select the first pair of inputs
we decided that we don't want to go
backward and forward because that seemed
pretty complicated
so we said that we are going to select
one input
bit at a time so as to get the maximum
number out now for this in order to set
it to zero or one you need a heuristic
to tell you
which one will get you more gates
so
using these probabilities which we i
mean you set a bit
and assume the remaining bits which are
yet not set are going to be zero or one
with equal probability
uh calculate the probabilities and so
this way you try to get one set of
inputs that covers
that covers almost almost half of the
of the total gates i mean for example
you know that no no input will detect
more than half of the stuck at faults
because
uh it
it only sets a gate value to zero or one
and so you get
at worse the gate has been stuck at the
wrong thing so so each input has a
maximum of 401
uh x's in its row yeah
and and but you were going to you're
going to choose the bits of this input
so that you would have some some row
that had lots of x's in it
something like that essentially this is
a heuristic estimate of uh how many how
many gates it will find
uh based on a bit
if you set a bit
and assuming the other bits are random
you have an estimate of how many gates
you have will have with zero how many
yeah now are you estimating on uh on
just total gates or on total
i mean un remaining ones yeah the
remaining faults i guess false is the
right word
so so you try to you so you so you
remember how many faults you've already
covered and then you then you say now
which bit would be a good one to try to
to uh to to cover as many of the of the
uncovered ones you know
really good estimates initially at least
when the number of remaining ones were
fairly large
for instance the first one simply by
sitting a bit to zero or one mm-hmm
with zero it gave an estimate of 378
gates when
the number was 382
i see and the second one i think it
gives somewhere around the order of 300
and 209 when it was 213.
okay so what did i
yeah let me let me uh i got some numbers
here uh
uh that uh in this
in my 14-step solution i said i first i
had to do this exhaustive search and i i
came up with these
with uh with three gates that were very
hard to cover one one only two ways to
do it and one and two of them only four
ways to do it and uh i exhaustively
found
uh of all combinations of these guys
which ones covered the most
of these you know these there was only
six or six or so cases to try
in fact one of the inputs covered two of
the hard ones uh
it was
147 times 223 this one covered two of
the hard ones
and so i probably wanted to use that
anyway that then then i um and so i use
those two as as my starting values and
then i started using a random a random
approach and
and uh
and so the first one that i put in
uh i had 455 gates uncovered then i put
in the second one by hand
and uh that had 307 gates uncovered okay
then i
um
i guess
i just use a random approach then for a
while
uh you know trial 50 or something like
that and take the one that covers the
most of those i didn't use this clever
method as you had and i got up to until
i was i had 12
12 inputs and four gates are still
uncovered
now at this point um
i decided to look at these four that
were uncovered and see what what
combinations of values on the gates
would be
would be needed so that i could do two
of these at a time
and so so then i could use my forward
and backward searching method
uh to to you know i had i said this gate
should be zero this gate should be one
then i'll cover both of these faults
and uh those two and so that's how i got
the final two
two
uh in there um
but that that gave me only 14 which is
not as good as 13 and so now i'd like to
ask
mike and roger how do you want to
you do to explain how you did here how
you did it
well
um
in a lot of ways the program wasn't
anywhere near as clever as some of the
other approaches which people seem to
have tried it doesn't um rely on any
knowledge about
the fact that it's dealing with a
multiplier circuit it's
just handling a general
network
of inputs and outputs
and
there's actually two steps to it
one program runs and tries to find a
sufficient cover
which will
cover all the faults and then another
program
takes the output from that program and
tries to reduce it
by okay so that's a did anybody else use
it have something like that so it's just
yeah so so in other words find a fine
first that's plus
a small
uh a
as a fairly small number of rows with
800
whatever it is one column
and and uh and then we have another
program that that finds the best cover
out of this small small number of rows
and what was the small number of rows
typical
roughly in your
case i mean well the sufficient cover
the station cover was 20.
you would get 20
and
with that but then you would just find
13 out of those 20. well it to get to
get down to 13 um
we ran the program more than once with a
couple of variations that would get
different outputs
and then i threw in by hand some like
also different variations because of
bugs in the program
uh
this is called the phase of the moon
yeah that's right
at several points the circuit has to the
um the first program has to make
decisions about which way it's going to
go in its search
and
by
adjusting the configuration of the
circuit you can
like it usually goes down the left side
before the right side or something like
that so if you just build an equivalent
circuit with a different description you
get different outputs
okay
and um
then i just so that was in general in
that sense i suppose i mean or it was
the program that generates the circuit
generates a random circuit is specific
to the multiplier i mean we have yeah
yeah but i meant this the one that
generates more
variations of the circuit
for this so that you can get different
starting points
was that also specific actually actually
it was more more of a case of
i mean using
i mean we this is at the time we had
about two different versions of the
search program
running
and
um and we checked we changed we changed
the programs
um
when
i mean deciding
well
which which which path of search was
going to take we change the criteria
slightly we get a different set of tests
and so every time every time we improve
the program and got a different set of
tests we just pump that all we just
dropped we had a file of sufficient
cases that right eventually ended up
with a file with about 100 inputs in it
okay and that got turned down to around
13.
and so then you look for at those
hundred which included
say five
six [ __ ] hours five groups of twenty
maybe uh each of which is each of which
is sufficient to cover
and then you found that 13 rows out of
that 100 would actually do that would
actually do it
in fact the
degree deceptive wasn't good enough to
get it down to 13 it could get it down
to 14 by
i see uh and so creed wasn't quite good
enough yeah okay let's get
somebody somebody up there will be glad
there's a moral here
uh to get down to 13 i just record going
in by hand and giving it some
suggestions about chances
oh it's just it's just like using the
seat yeah you say okay well we so you
you looked at it you looked at this 105
800 matrix that you said now i looked at
the uh i looked at the time it got 14
and um i guessed that one of its early
inputs was a wrong guess and so i just
took that out of the file and didn't let
it have that as a choice okay so it
doesn't hurt to interact with a program
like this too
we're not uh
competing like in the crypto problem we
were competing against a
human intelligence that had set this uh
message
but the uh but in this case it's nature
like a very logical embodiment of nature
who was decided what the stuck at faults
are
uh
or in his covering problem
yeah okay so so so that was the the last
phase of it was to take this hundred
bullet down to 13 and that was a
combination of of hand methods and uh
and and uh has anybody verified
independently that these 13 really are
correct
no actually
i i i remember mike came to and showed
them to me at midnight
and uh and the main thing i wanted to
know is if he had one of these two guys
in there because if he didn't i would be
pretty suspicious but he did
so
okay in fact that must have shown up in
your 100k you know that you would have
have these in all five
um we did we didn't look at them very
carefully
how did you generate your sufficient
codes now that's the important thing
that's the right that's the that's where
the real
the real interest is but i wanted to
to to get the end game out off the stack
now so that so now we have uh we have
only one more sub problem remaining how
did you get this sufficient cover
any other questions
what is that because of the running time
because of running time running time and
flakiness in the implementation of bliss
people oh this is on on
yeah stack limitations and weird
undocumented compiler problem
or at least i wish half of the
compiler writers of the world would have
gone through the stanford educational
system and it wouldn't be so bad
okay
okay so so fast
but when you pascal doesn't work that
well either but then you have to you
have to do more and you're on your own
and you keep a little more track of your
bits i guess or know what you're doing i
don't know okay mike
um
the
we did we don't use any of the
symbolic techniques basically at any
point in solution
all we know about
gates in the circuit is whether their
output is 0 1 or unknown so far
and
we
pick a fault and try to
try to find some specification of input
values which will
some assignment of input values which
will force that fault to be detected
uh how do you pick up
how do you define default
as they say
the origin how do we decide which fault
to force yeah or how to force the folder
well you've got it so so you've
you've got a memory for each gate of
what its current value is
zero one or or
unknown and also on each gate there's a
flag for each fault for the two possible
forces okay so this gate has previously
been we've previously covered this or
not
uh
okay so you so so you've got
some memory of
of uh
uh it's a little bit like what you said
i mean
you were using a probabilistic uh
approach but it's similar to that you
you you say uh for example here's a gate
uh so far i've uh i've i've been able to
cover it stuck at zero but not at one
that's and therefore uh
all the things being equal i'd rather
try to make it equal to zero now because
so that i can detect the stuck at one
fault uh
with some
with some
hope okay
so you choose a gate
at the initially your first gate that
you
tried was what one of the outputs or one
of the inputs as it turned out we we
started closer to the outputs and more
towards the inputs that was
we previously numbered the gates um
starting from the influx so that um the
inputs of any gate had lower numbers
than the gate itself okay and then we
just work from high and if you had any
any other numbering of that then you
would come up with a different uh
sufficient cover and that and generate
other numbers
so with any circuit you could have some
way of shuffling these numbers
preserving that condition
and you would get another starting kit
yeah okay
and
then to
that's the main the main routine in the
program
is one which tries to force the output
of given gate to a given value
and it just has a bunch of rules in it
um which recursively if you're in an
input then you're done
if you're the nand gate and you're
trying to force it to one then you force
both inputs to one
these sorts of rules
okay so so we know that uh that there's
there's two forcing cases and gate to
one and a four gate to zero but the
other cases
or
as uh at least in my program i thought
that i wanted to
if i wanted to force exclusive order to
be zero then i wanted to force the two
inputs to be equal
uh
well but you didn't do that or forced
them both to zero but it's one yeah so
you did you branched yeah um
uh and so this like this fancy uh
equivalence class or union find
algorithm stuff who
didn't appear in your program at all
that's correct
essentially there were two ways of
making the decision i mean one was you
look at the two gates that are
underneath and you see which gates which
um like for instance let's take the case
of the and gate that we're trying to
force to zero
okay there's an end gate to zero okay
and
well another thing that gets passed to
this procedure that is forcing the
advantage this is this
detecting parameter which says force the
and gate to zero and not only that um if
this parameter say is true then force it
to zero and not only that if there is
some stuck at fault then we're going to
actually see it at the output
so that um
so it's supposed to go forward as well
well the idea is
um
i mean if you call it with this
parameter being false that means force
it to zero but
we're not going to see it at the output
so anything so so don't worry about
trying to find as many well the idea
okay say this people say this parameter
was true yeah so that what we see at the
end gate's going to appear at the output
that is if the end cape
produces a different output because of
some stuck at fault at the and gate or
beneath it
then
it's going it's going to appear at the
output so what we try to do
is make it zero by making one of the
inputs zero one of the inputs one rather
than doing both the input zero
because then
the input that zero will also be
detected at the output
um
let's see an and gate in order to for an
and gate to get
you can still make one's
okay i mean these
you can't make ones out of zeros only
exactly but still there's other ones
sitting around insert
okay so so but but you actually does
your procedure actually go forward as
well as backward you have you have this
one thing is giving an and gate and
you're saying force something about its
inputs what about outputs
there's another procedure which says
given this and gate make it visible to
the to the output
and that's a recursive call to the
parent okay so visible means visible
means that if the outputs other from
what it's supposed to be that's going to
show up on an output on an output of the
multiplier
well another thing that gets passing
that gets passed to this procedure that
is forcing the end base this is this
detecting parameter which says force the
and gate to zero
and not only that um if this parameter
says true then force it to zero and not
only that if there is some stuck at
fault then we're going to actually see
it at the output
so that um
so it's supposed to go forward as well
well the idea is um
i mean if you call it with this
parameter being false that means
force it to zero but
we're not going to see it at the output
so anything so so don't worry about
trying to find as many well the idea
okay say this people say this parameter
was true yeah so so that what we see at
the end gate is going to appear at the
output that is if the end cape
produces a different output because of
some stuck at fault at the and gate or
beneath it
then
it's going it's going to appear at the
output so what we try to do
is make it zero by making one of the
inputs zero one of the inputs one rather
than doing both the input to zero
because then
the input that's zero will also be
detected at the output
um
let's see an and gate in order to for an
and gate to get
you can still make one's fencing
okay i mean the api can make
there's other ones sitting around that
circle okay so but but do you actually
does your procedure actually go forward
as well as backward you have you have
this one thing that's giving an and gate
and you're saying force something about
its inputs what about outputs there's
there's another procedure which says
given this and gate make it visible to
the to the output
and that's a recursive call to the
parent okay so visible means visible
means that if the outputs other from
what it's supposed to be that's going to
show up on an output on an output of the
multiplier
so that is you've got i know what it
means but how does the what does it mean
to the program how does the program
enforce visibility well it's its
assumption is that if there's a path of
gates between this gate and the output
and each end gate along the path has the
other input one and each or gate has the
other input zero
then the gate is visible it's
so it's a heuristic but not uh
but not guaranteed so so you're saying
that if there's a path from
let's see you you say below
sits at the top of the office at the top
okay but here's a here's an output
and you've got some path here
and you've got an and gate
and you've got some ore gates and you've
got some exclusive or gates
and so on that you don't care about
and uh
and then we've got this gate
okay g here which you want to get up you
want to make visible at this output at
some output and um you um are
saying that this
on the r was a zero this on the end was
a
one
on the other the exclusive voice you
don't know what was we forced to either
zero or one but we but it's still
visible
you you force them to zero one why um
because we want to know
what their output is going to be
okay
the basic idea is that to make to make g
visible
you have to make sense if there's that
or gate above it you have to make the
other input of the or zero and then you
have to make that or gate visible and so
it's recursive that way
so um
uh
and and uh this is is uh the interesting
thing about this is that it's not
correct
that's right um but it's just a it's
what they call a heuristic uh in the in
in one of the senses of the word that
says it's it's it's mostly correct
that's right there's several places
actually in the program
where we have heuristics like that
and
the
the reason we don't worry about the fact
they're not guaranteed is that once we
finally decided that we're gonna that
we've found an input which will be
useful
we then run it through another part of
the program which does one of these
parallel simulations so in other words
even though greed might not win
dishonesty seems to
be all right
i'm not i'm not accusing kathy of being
a bad influence on this
i don't know well actually
yes
somebody wants him when you have
we have reconversion effects
you can have
um
it might be that g and g are both
are both visible for example like this
but uh if you try if you try first to
force this path to be
visible to the output then you will find
eventually the
inconsistency so you have to backtrack
anyway it's only one path no no no no
the problem is
that it doesn't it doesn't catch
everything and also that
when you actually have the fault at that
gate it might change
so you say that that it actually is
supposed to give a a wrong output up
here
you you have you have only one you have
one value of the of the circuit you
don't have you don't have the correct
the true value in the
and the bad value do you
it's just one value you just have one
charge today what it's supposed to be
and so
and so uh uh so so that's the test of
visibility doesn't know
doesn't also also keep track of uh
whether or not uh it came through so so
for example if this was a a simple case
we have g here and g here
and this is your output
uh
so um
uh
a g is actually being used as both
inputs to that to that gate so they
would think that that d is zero for
example and they would set set this plus
to a uh to a value like zero or one i
mean let's say and then uh
then the output
would be there and they would think that
that was visible
we did something
finally we tried to
to use your mechanical union find
and
we covered four additional gates with
that and our approach was that first we
generate the path from before the gate
to the output a path yes impact
forcing those
ones the engage and zero to the old
gauge
and then
try to work backwards and forwards and
if we find any consistency then we
backtrack and eventually choose another
part until you get to or else you'll
find that it's impossible yeah that's a
that's a good that's a very good uh
but there are four to the 19th plants or
something like
yeah um
four to the nineteenth is a larger
general idea just to get an input well
that this is like yeah i want to return
i got to try to cover all the basics but
one of the things i i wanted to mention
is that this
in uh in
um in general uh searching in in ai uh
there's this uh
um
uh this this the the kind of forward and
backward propagation of values that are
that are going on in
in
many of the programs described are is is
a special case of the general idea of
of um
i can't remember the right buzzwords i'm
sorry but uh but where you have more
than two values and so you have you know
multiple valued things and and and and
other inputs in the and uh the the
problem of detecting stuck at faults
is is a special case of a general
problem of hypothesis uh
uh
validation or something like this in our
presentation where they where you try to
say
what for example you have some kind of a
of a of a of a
model of a
um
of a system that you think is is is
complete and you say well now uh
what what uh
in case
let me try to design an experiment that
would that would maybe re refute this
hypothesis and if you look at the
question of what would be the what would
be one of the most
effective experiments to try to see
whether or not whether or not
a scientific hypothesis is valid um
that turns out to be uh um
essentially the same as the problem of
stuck at fault in in in the zero one
case
um and there's uh mike jones showed me a
paper where they applied this to
this is this kind of a method to things
like
symbolic integration i believe
um so anyway the kinds of methods that
we use on this particular problem
will also
will also uh
make other problems simpler that that
we're going to find that you'll find you
know you you you look for some other
things someday and you'll say hey that's
rather similar to the
to something that we would do doing that
sound that was that seemed to only only
relate to gates
um
okay now now they
go ahead
yeah
having chosen the gate a fault let's say
let's say found an input which will
cover it some of your input bits may yet
be answered not set yet that's right so
you would probably want to pick up one
more fault and try to satisfy them so
how do you select that so so coming back
here and and and making this one he's
got to call this receipt procedure that
that that forces that to be a one right
fine it's covered let's say yeah but
there's still some input bits which are
not set so you can go ahead and cover
another fault maybe that's right so how
do you select your next one the same
ordering you just keep working through
the gates in decreasing numerical order
so he finds that
say the largest gate that has yet not
been covered
basically the gate closes to the output
and wait until all the inputs are
have a value and and and then that
becomes one of the the
things for your sufficient cover and
then you
and then you erase all the inputs and
and try to get again now it seems to me
that one of the key things in this
that's making this
work as well we haven't focused on it
yet it's how you choose
which uh
what what values to force on your on
your inputs uh if you're trying to force
a zero and a hand gate or something like
that uh but the uh uh but it but he but
uh he's got the the thing that you are
doing with your probabilistic method
that is you have a memory of what you've
already covered
um and that and that guides you in
choosing the next case was quite
different from the method that that i
that i used every time i
attacked this circuit
i was just at
tableau i was just starting over with uh
you know the same as before
uh with with no with no knowledge of
what i what was easy to cover otherwise
unless i had some some
method i put in by hand saying here's
the gate that i'd like to try now
and so so
you've got a lot of memory of what are
potentially fruitful things or what are
things that are still waiting to be
explored that you haven't you haven't
tried these you have never covered these
faults yet so you've got that
as a guide to saying what's going to
what's going to help out is that right
so so let's look at that anyway this is
this this was this picture of visibility
is the one thing i think we understand
now that they have a a heuristic for
visibility
that would say
that um that probably g will be visible
but not for sure there's a chance that
it's
that it will cancel through um and then
then there's this final there's this
final test afterwards to uh
to to make sure that the that these
heuristic assumptions were were in fact
justified
but it was but this heuristic has that
has the advantages of a good heuristic
that is it's uh
it's usually true and it it
effectively narrows down the search
and and has a fairly simple control
because you have this parameter that's
either true or false if it's true you go
you go to the outputs and
and try to get a visible path through
and that's a recursive situation where
it tries to where there's one procedure
that's called forcing uh
for force this value force force this
value to be be
one or something like that so when you
when you're forcing let's see you
suppose you you call a parameter true at
g
so then it comes through this and gate
and the and gate wants to force this
value to be one what's the parameter on
that call it depends what the other
input is if the other input is a one
that then the parameter will be true
because
let's say okay see that end and there's
both inputs one right
then
a stuck at fault that shows up on the
right input to that will also go through
to the output we'll also change
but if it's zero then you don't care
whether it is but if it's zero then it's
going to be blocked no matter what it is
okay but it really doesn't matter
because you're going to have made this
one visible anyway so you would i mean
the idea is to make the idea is to make
g visible but
this looks like if it's if it's in steps
from the bottom you would be checking
for visibility several times you would
well you've got a force output all the
way up yeah and okay we just have these
rules which try to pick up extra gates
along the way if we can okay so now
you've got an output and if you want to
force to zero and the question is what
what to force it on its inputs
for example uh
uh we just covered the first we just
covered 370 faults and now we're
and we've used up all our inputs so now
we're going to try the largest fault
that hasn't been covered
and there's two
there's two sorts of rules one is
um
since we're this gate how are we doing
on time i wanna we've got about five
minutes oh good any faults on this gate
are going to be detected
otherwise we wouldn't be trying to force
its output
presumably um oh that's not true okay no
no assuming assuming that faults are
going to be detected
then we can try to
detect extra volts below this gate okay
so there's a couple of rules that work
on that and then the other so so so
if you go to one side
on the left-hand side you you you have a
choice of
of trying to force zero on the left
uh and not and not carrying on the right
or you can force zero on the right and
and and do that first
or you could try to force zero on both i
guess four four zero one or force one so
zero one or fourth yeah and in fact in
the case where we're trying to
where we are detecting faults on that or
we think we are anyway
and say the left input
has not had us stuck it um has not had
stuck at one fault detected on it
because the right one input has
then we want to try and detect that
not yet
okay stuck at one so that's the one we
forced to zero and then we force the
right one right input to one
and and this one is not just what did
you say
anything about that one right now
not making any assumptions about that
not making any assumptions
you would force a zero but why would you
force a one on that because if we have a
one on the other one then we'll detect
this stuck at one on that left-hand gate
ah
i see it's the same rule as because in
order to make it visible you wouldn't
want it you would want to put a zero
there okay so then you would try this
and that's recursive both of these these
methods would try okay which would be
called uh
uh to force
uh
to force to see if that's an and gate it
does the same thing again well except
that the one we set on the one on the
left we're setting the detecting
parameter whereas on the one one on the
right we're not gonna don't bother to go
up on some on one branch and go because
you know that this one is this branch
whatever happens on the right branch is
not gonna be it's not gonna be visible
assuming the left branch is working
correctly
okay so that that's a that's a cut off
that you you would have recognized if
you didn't have that parameter you would
have recognized it a little slower
that it wasn't visible
the other thing we do and if there isn't
any any sort of i mean if we are dealing
with a tabula rasa in instance or some
kind but we don't have any any way of
saying well this gate hasn't had this
fault detected on and this gate has we
don't have any of that to go by the
other thing that we do is we have the
circuit building program
rearrange
the inputs to the gates
um such that
it's always nicer to force the left
input to be a zero and the right input
to be to be a one
nicer nicer well
as you can hear we get into morality and
monster basically means that it will
actually cause more constraints on the
circuit which means that if it's going
to fail in other words
you like to you you would like to uh uh
you say it's nicer to set the left one
to a two zero and the right one to a one
right
in other words if it's an n if if the
two inputs one of them is a is an r gate
you would like to put the or gate on the
left
and um and if there's an end game in
line you might be right and it's like to
be at the right so basically the circuit
building program because then you would
have a another
uh idea as to what would be
that zero one would be a nice thing to
try i mean if you're just given a choice
between trying zero one and one zero
then
all
right
the the search program automatically
assumes
first you would like to try that first
because it gives you more
more uh
less more cases that you can go through
without branching
at the beginning okay so that's another
heuristic for uh
avoiding branching because because once
you've found this
once you've covered that fault
you don't have to
um you don't have to consider the other
branches that
that would have covered it in hard case
and so you might as well try to try to
take cases that that have a forced force
case because you're forcing an and gate
to be one then you have no
no no decision at all
nelson also do something similar on the
make visible routine because you have a
choice of which parent to go through
and so
you can have the circuit building pork
program just sort the parents in order
of
what will make the best
i mean the idea would make visibles to
get to the top as fast as you can
and so if you can go through an exor
gate then go through a next door gate
and then i did some i did studies on
that circuit by the way to find out how
hard it was to which were the the hard
gates to make visible and uh and it
turned out that uh
almost all of them
were easy to make visible and
uh gosh i don't
i don't have my my uh
outputs in there but it turned out that
it's like that some somehow um oh but
yeah all but um
a dozen or maybe 20 were
uh
uh had us had a had a path that was that
was all
and gates are all
nutsy it had no um
i guess it had had none of these
none of these cases where that where
your your heuristic broke down i guess
is what is another way to say say what i
was doing the coefficient when i in in
my uh
in my representation of g equals
something
f
f plus h
f could be factored into a product of
of um
of uh
inputs and and complements of inputs
there is an interesting quantification
of what you are just saying in our
program where we where we maintain the
probability of of an of a fault being at
any gate being propagated out
and in most cases the probability
regardless of the inputs with the inputs
being random was 0.95
ah
except in a few cases for instance in
one case it was 0.005
where there was only one output path
okay but
okay so except for 506 cases okay so
that that vindicates your
characterization of the of the
methods here
okay um
well
now so the comments so the combination
of lots of
lots of good ideas seem to have made
this made for this winning solution of
13 and uh
and uh so that makes three problems in a
row in which i've been
uh pleasantly surprised by the by the
outcome although i know
the um
others of you are
wishing that
that you'd been as lucky too but uh i
still think that
that the method people have described
have been
have been
pretty pretty good and interesting even
the ones that didn't come up with the
record but i think maybe 13 will be the
world record for this circuit
right so that's a
that's it then for our
our
class discussion of problem three
thursday we
will work we'll begin on problem four we
have four four class sessions on problem
four while everyone is also working on
problem five we hope
all right
okay